skies business correspondent paul kelso
is across this story and joins us from
the newsroom with more port what do you
know
we know that this is the latest
manifestation of the supply chain
squeeze caused particularly by an acute
lack of hgv drivers that has been
dominating the thoughts of business and
indeed corners of government as their
concern about the to this supply of
everything from food to manufactured
goods we've been talking about energy
haven't we really for the last week and
the impact of that on supply but in the
background this driver shortage has been
ongoing and bp saying they've been
unable to deliver petrol and diesel to
some of their four courts not because
they don't have enough but because they
just simply cannot get it there because
they can't get the drivers they have
issued a statement which i can give you
here so we're experiencing fuel supply
issues at some of our retail sites in
the uk and unfortunately have therefore
seen a handful of sites temporarily
close
due to a lack of both unleaded and
diesel grades these have been caused by
delays in the supply chain which has
been impacted by industry-wide driver
shortages across the uk and we're
working hard to address this issue we
continue to work with our haulier
suppliers to minimize disruption and to
ensure efficient and effective
deliveries to serve our customers we
apologize for any inconvenience
caused
now the industry has been calling for
the government to act to help ease this
driver shortage the industry estimates
around 90 000 drivers
shortage we know
that around 15 000 european union
drivers have left since 2019 left the uk
not returned to the road in total around
50 000 drivers have gone since the
pandemic began many of those who left
may been able to work had they decided
to come back but anyone who didn't have
leave to remain a european union driver
will now not get a visa to work here and
the industry's been asking and today
logistics uk has asked the government to
grant 10 000 emergency visas short-term
visas to allow low-skilled workers as
hgv drivers are classified to come to
the uk and work thus far the
government's line has been
no simply they want to train and hire
domestic drivers to fill this gap they
see this as a chance to help increase
the terms and indeed the wages of
domestic workers lorry drivers wages are
rising the demand is huge many companies
offering big signing on fees tesco
complaining in a meeting with the
government last week that in fact the
big signing fees were effectively just
shuffling the deck tears
around they're moving a finite number of
drivers around the real problem here is
a shortage and bp the latest to be
affected